good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Tuesday hope everybody's
having a blessed truly blessed truly
truly blessed day thus far speaking
blessed speaking blessed allow me to
introduce someone I'm so blessed to have
in my life it's Jackie thank you lot
turd seven blessings on your head seven
blessings on your head may peace be with
you yes I hope you have a blessed day as
well it's a Tuesday starting off with
your girly swirly so it's it's off to a
good start I'm hoping yeah I I don't
want to jinx it or anything but I just
have a feeling today's episode is going
to be like so cute you know cute do you
think it's going to be cute because I'm
wearing a dress uh no cuz I didn't even
know you were wearing a seam loss so I
literally said it was going to be a cute
episode before I even saw your bottom
half cuz I can only see you from chest
up so I'm wearing a Seamon I just want
to I just want to give a quick
background I want to talk about it
quickly because I never wear a seam lot
on this remote setup and now I'm
remembering why so usually like when I
have something to do right now today
after this like I have to be wearing a
seam La for something so I was like why
not wear a seam LA on the show instead
of like wearing a sweatshirt and then
changing I did that last week at had a
lunch and it's like why not look nice on
the show wow she had a lunch on she was
lunching let's talk about the spelling
of the word luncheon not before I finish
talking about my seam La just make a
note we'll do so I was like why not just
wear my lovely SE I knew I was going to
wear this after the show just wear it on
the show
and I'm not feeling it you want to know
why first of all the remote set up the
remote set up with the headphones like
you can't wear headphones and a SEMA
like this no I disagree I that's like
what are you going to say if you want to
keep like cutting me off in the middle
of my seam monologue I I know why you
wouldn't wear a seam it's the same
reason I wouldn't wear a seam uh knees I
know knees but I was like you know what
that's a me problem I'm going to go past
the knees cuz like I'd rather look nice
on the show and have my knees show than
like where another day of wearing a
sweatshirt oh that's where you and I
differ my friend but it's like it's just
not the vibe of the chair and the setup
and the headphones make it just like you
know a different you're not supposed to
be wearing a dress with these big
headphones you're just not no if you're
wearing like a big dress and big
headphones like it's giving
emo I guess oh I wasn't even thinking
that it's just so conflicting the two
Vibes like this is like ethereal girly
pretty and then this is like Tactical
emo that makes it even worse I come
downstairs and change no you look gorina
vagina you have to try new things no I
do like outside of this chair in this
room and this angle like I love my FIT I
know it's not me it's like it's the
setup and this was what I fear this was
what I feared everyone sound off in the
comments about how beautiful Jackie
looks and how her knees are just giving
young wait the thing is you can't even
see my KNE knees because this dress is
like it's a it's not a long dress but
when I sit there's a lot of extra
material so it's below my knees it's
just kind of a disaster today well I
only see you from titties up and let me
just say you're looking
gorgeous oh wow classy broad oh that's a
lot of dress I know that's what I'm
saying listen you made the decision and
now we're going to live with it so
embrace the sea I I wanted to say why
I'm wearing a sea and why I won't be
wearing a on the future even though I
have a lot of days down here where right
after the show I put on a nice dress and
why we can't have nice dresses on this
show this is why it's not 100% right I'm
also like kind of wearing something
crazy you are wearing a fendy sweater
and this is a fendy sweater that like I
purchased at a heavier weight and it was
like I I didn't I I don't love
purchasing I always felt like when I was
heavier like this is not permanent this
is just a temporary situation even
though it lasted about 10 years so I
didn't like love investing in things cuz
I'm like well when my time comes I'm not
going to be able to wear it and the idea
of my time coming was always this sort
of like mystical futuristic thing that
was never going to happen but it
happened and I'm like well I invested in
a few good things and I haven't worn
this sweater in a really long time and
today I was just like you know what it's
giving oversized and the good thing
about like nobody ever making anything
in my size is that when I was much
heavier this sweater really didn't
actually fit me like never would have
zipped it it was more of just like an
open moment and now that I'm smaller it
zips and it's just like oversized and
I'm embracing it yeah that's really not
that crazy to like have bought a sweater
in a large size and then wear it like
when you're smaller it's not like
something that has to be super
fitted I um like I engaged in your seam
La gate and you could engage in my
cardigan gate if you wanted to I I yeah
I can but I just feel
like it's not that crazy I say it was
crazy I just thought that there was like
a lot that went into picking out the
sweater yeah and I feel like it's less
about you know the size because you can
be smaller and get size large but more
about like the logo Mania that you're
wearing a fendy sweater yeah this was
one of my investments many many years
ago when did I purchase this it wasn't
the one I made you buy no I think I got
this actually for a steal on the real
reel if I'm remembering correctly love
it even better yeah yeah yeah and it
works at any size you're saying it
appears so sound off in the comments do
I look stunning or what Sisterhood of
the Traveling sweater yes exactly so
crazy that Serena Bender Woodson was in
that movie and they all wee the same
pants yeah do you think on set there was
only one pair of pants or that
no Serena was 6 feet tall like there was
no way they were all different sizes
there was no way that one pair of jeans
was fitting all of them okay who was it
Alexis Bledel America Ferrera Blake
Lively and Amber Tamlin no they all are
different heights sizes everything
that's kind of
shitty yeah Jackie it's a movie it's
called magical realism I know but I
don't know it's just like okay if
they're not really all wearing the same
pants what's the
point like I hear you but it's not a
play like it's it's a movie you know no
I know but it's like what's the
message I don't know to me it seems like
even like more farfetch and fantasy if
they're not wearing the same pants than
like Chronicles of
Narnia wow yeah know it's definitely up
there in terms of like Fantastical ISM
with Harry Potter yeah it's like you
have to World build and believe they
could all wear the same pants right and
not only did they all wear the same
exact pair of jeans they all liked the
way that they looked which would never
happen even if there are two girls with
the same exact bodies you give them both
a pair of pants they're not both going
to like them like jeans are so personal
yeah I just feel like it's a plot hole
in the movie and the movie wasn't worth
making if they couldn't all get in the
same pair of jeans wow that's like a
very hot and I want to say bad take no I
know it's very hot and the thing is
there are so many other great Parts
about the movie like Blake Lively and
the soccer coach and the grease and you
know and America Ferrera standing up to
her parents for sure and the other girl
she was like not having a good summer
right Amber tamin I think it's been a
while I think her mom died oh I that's
not what I remember but then she
certainly wasn't having a good summer no
yes someone's mom
died I think it was the soccer
player it's not a Coming of Age movie
unless the mother is dead yeah so yes as
I was saying there's things other than
the jeans in the
movie
but the jeans should have fit
everyone well they didn't they might
have no way let me Google it let me see
and like justice for America Ferrera for
like the the entirety of her early
career like always being cast as like a
token fat person when she lowy like
wasn't even fat no that happens a lot
like when you take a step back and you
realize like oh that's supposed to be
like you know what fat was considered
like she was so normal
looking yeah I didn't know that that was
her role in the movie okay there's too
many yeah that's why they like couldn't
believe that the pants fit America well
also there was tall and short yeah yeah
yeah but you
know I know and I can't talk about
America Ferrera and actually nay I won't
talk about America Ferrera without
ending the sentence CIP
wether yeah now that is a movie worth
discussing now that's a message we can
all agree on what sport were they
playing in that movie volleyball if we
both think it must be true and is that a
dcom Disney Channel original film it's
hard to know if it was a decom or
acquired by the D right it's hard to
know if it was a dcom or it was just
getting the D yeah
that's such a good movie and you're
right the message C like you can we can
do this is something that has carried me
through the majority of my adult life
yeah it's giving like Moder day Rosie
the
Riveter it's giving Moder day Rosie the
Riveter and that's just a universal
Eternal message we can do
it what else can we do tury we can do
this show and we can do it flawlessly
might I add we also can talk about our
respective book clubs because I know
your book club met yesterday mine did as
well the thing about my book club is
you'll all be privy to our council
meeting on Thursday when the episode
drops it was a great episode plus it was
our end of year recap episode we rated
the best redheads books of the year and
our favorite books that we read for the
year
extracurricularly but the conversation
about the Memoir was really riveting and
varied and multifaceted and the thing
that's frustrating and if I had just
read Britney's Memoir I would have been
like it's so good Claude read it it's
brief it's quick I told you my issue was
that it wasn't very deep it kind of
scratched the surface and everybody else
had that issue too I can't really
withstand book club
scrutiny yet we had to do our jobs yeah
I understand that we had a totally
different experience at book club last
night like finally we all liked the book
now AB was being like a naysayer but
he's just a contrarian and we just
ignore him everybody loved the book it
was such a good it's a great book club
Choice like so many people um had
different things to contribute so many
people didn't even watch friends but
still had like so much to take away from
it and there was just a really great
conversation about addiction for you
know some people in the group who maybe
haven't been touched by addiction or
really don't know the extent of like how
much of a disease it is I think it's
really helpful in for me like that was
like how dopesick like totally taught me
so much about addiction I think a lot of
people had that experience with with
this book it was such a good book club
book finally like we ended the year on a
good note after just like you know Loser
book after Loser book after Loser book
it happens it happens that's just kind
of the nature of book club yeah everyone
thinks book club it's like Fire books
every month but no there's lows and
there's highs yeah and we had finally
hit a high last night and we went out to
eat you know we're the babusa book club
we usually do a homecooked meal but it
was the end of the year I was supposed
to host but with everything going on
with Theo like I just my house is a dump
and every understood so then we thought
it' be nice to have like a little
holiday party for the end of the year we
went to a kosher restaurant that I had
never been to but that's like a classic
institution in the city Laray have you
been mm let me tell you it was so good
except and this is the most classic
kosher restaurant thing on the planet
sat down not every room was area just
three of the girlies we were like we're
going to have a soda hi maybe we have
three dieet Cokes please of course comes
back we're all out of die Coke like
that's just so classic kosher restaurant
like running out of die Coke so we had
to settle for Coke Zero Yik not the same
not the same yikes so it like that could
have deterred the book club because like
that for me was Monumental before
everyone even got there things were
going arai but you know we got it back
on track what are you reading next month
we haven't chosen yet so next this month
wasn't anybody's particular choice we
because it was the end of the year
everybody nominated a book and then
voted on on another book this was my
nomination the Matthew Perry book so
yeah I got to get like a check in my in
my column um and then we start back at
the top of the list in January with
Raquel okay and what's her vibe
hystorical fiction right she's a little
all over the place you know the last
book she chose was so unrack because
she's very smart you know so she'll
always go for something intellectual she
chose one Italian summer and I was like
okay not your best work Rael but I think
she knows that and so she's going to
really like come out strong she's going
to step it up yeah she's going to step
her [__] up next month we have Margo's
choice I can't remember what she chose
there was a lot going on towards the end
end of the episode it got really crazy I
had to do like my math for the top
redheads books of the year because we
all like rank them a lot I want to know
what Marco chose so think about it let
me just text her and hopefully we'll get
a response because what's so funny and
this is how you know Margot like is half
in on the redheads but we had a
conversation about this on yesterday's
episode like she's not allowed to go
anywhere oh I was talk to texting by the
way talk to text is my new favorite
thing one second what book did you
choose for the redheads question mark
did you choose a book question
markk I also question mark I also told
her if this is what happened drama at
the end of every episode we talk about
the other books that we read this month
everybody gives a little monologue I
know people tune each other out they
check their phones while one person's
talking it doesn't really require a
response then Margo goes to tell her
book and she's like we're reading Tom
Lake by Anne patchet I'm like Dana
literally just said she just read that
like could you be paying less attention
oh that's frustrating right but it's
fine I mean I could cut it out what did
she say she said oh she didn't cuz I
told her take more time to pick your
book and then just record the blurb and
we'll add it to the episode Insider
secret also something really exciting
redheads programming is we are doing
Margot and I and you're welcome to join
us if you finish the book we're doing a
little iron flame B bonus episode oh my
God okay so I picked iron flame back up
again
yesterday
I'm this book sucks okay but does the
idea of podcasting about it make you
want to finish it like a little bit such
a long way to go I know I might be at
42% like I honestly and it's the end of
the year I feel like I want to start
reading like a lot of good short books
like Thrillers just to get my Goodreads
up and this book is delaying me because
I'm dreading every time I pick up my
Kindle what's your Goodreads number at
right now that's a question last year I
crushed it and so I'm I'm going to be
less than last year which I hate
oh I just hit my my goal of the year
which was 40 which was I'm at 42 a
conservative goal but that was like
sorry I'm at 40 comma to I got that I
surmised but others might not have yeah
so I don't know I don't know what I'm
going to do about this iron
FL I'll let you know when we're
recording so you can see if you want to
finish it by then but what I was saying
about talk to text is that one of my
resolutions and maybe my only one is I
want to get better at answering my texts
that would be so fabulous I answer your
Tech I talk to you every minute of the
day no you don't answer my text we don't
text a lot we FaceTime like 35 times a
day okay but I'm not talking about you
literally I couldn't be more
communicative with you no no you could
and that's the problem no you have my
full communication you can't add
yourself to the list of that's your full
no but I'm saying if that's your full
communication it's not good oh wow okay
I'm I'm not even worried about that I'm
worried about just like I'll wake up in
the middle of the night sometimes be
like I didn't answer that person's text
and it's like not someone I text that
often it's rude it's [__] rude so I'm
now trying to text more I'm utilizing
talk to text and I will be utilizing
voice notes because sometimes I just get
so overwhelmed with having to describe
something that I don't voice note but
the hard part about being a girl who
talks to text and sends voice memos is
that sometimes you'll be talking to text
and you'll be thinking you're recording
a voice memo so you put like personality
and and you know personification sounds
in there and it doesn't translate that's
not my issue my issue is when I do a
voice note hey how are Youk comma period
exactly but it's better than not
answering at all agreed so that's where
I'm at that's what I'm working on I
think that's a really good resolution I
think that is too I know you don't do
resolutions cuz I'm a perfect person cuz
you're a perfect person but if you did
would there any anything you would
resolve there are a few things but I
don't want to share them oh they're
personal yeah huh tury keeping things
close to the vest yeah I'm a very
private person who just finished her
period good good good good I'm glad it's
over you and me both sister thank you
for keeping us a breast I always am
anyways I we were talking about our book
clubs all went
well and that's what's new with us yeah
yeah we've got a great show hopefully a
super cute one super cute oh I keep
chuckling to myself because I keep
expanding in my mind on the reference
you made about an emo girl in the dress
and the headphones and like that's
literally that's me today yeah thank you
I'm glad you see the vision yeah no it's
it's too real I think it's also the fact
that your dress is pink and your
headphones are black pink and black is
one of the worst color combinations of
all time and it's so emo girl yeah no
that's me hey that's me so we're just
going to push through we're going to
push through in the seam Law Without
further we' we've been through tougher
times oh for sure without further
adoo here are the fast five stories that
you need to know and the Fast Five stor
that you need to know very appropriately
is brought to you by Jenny Kane and the
gorgeous apparel from Jenny Kane Winter
is right around the corner and our
wardrobe could definitely use a refresh
Jenny Kane is a California brand through
and through their Staples make getting
dressed easier than it's ever been been
before think minimalist and effortless
but totally refined so we have a big
trip coming up we've been talking a lot
about getting like our Chic Coastal
Grand neutral energy Kashmir sweaters on
fleek and jenic Cane is the exact vibe
that we are going for for winter in
general especially for our upcoming trip
in any season but this one especially
their sweaters are the it item I
actually just got a few more sweaters
they have a bunch of quarter Zips which
I love they're made so well they're so
they're so Nancy Myers like Jenny Kane
ex Nancy Meers we need that collab like
yesterday it would just be more Jenny
Kane yeah so the Flynn cashmere sweater
is one of my favorite sweaters from
Jenny Kane it's the perfect to wear with
anything v-neck they also have the
cashmere half zip I got it in two colors
that's the one I was talking about
they're um back in stock now with a
bunch of different shades and we are
adding both to our carts perfect for the
holiday gifting season it's a great
really nice thing to give someone I have
a cardigan my first thing that I ever
got from Jenny Kane that I got like
three years ago it is in great condition
it's just made really well if you want
to invest in something really nice and
wellmade that'll last you winter after
winter after winter check out Jenny Cade
they've also got the best collection of
quality shoes they style so easily with
anything they've got the Brooklyn lug
boot it's a cold weather classic and the
leather lug mule which is a new favorite
they also have a stunning collection of
Home Essentials everything Jenny Kane
home is like what I aspire to be and I
actually am getting a couch from Jenny
Kane for my new apartment CU I'm totally
changing it up like very Coastal Grand
energy um GI gift yourself and your
loved ones the best gift of all Jenny
Kane our listeners get 15% off your
first order when you go and use our code
toast at Jenny kane.com that's 15% off
your first order at JN k a y ne.com code
toast let getting dress be one less
thing to worry about today's episode is
also brought to you by Honey Love we've
officially made it to December which
means it's time for 12 days of deals at
Honey Love are go-to for bras and
shapewear December 1st and 12th honey
love will be dropping new limited
edition items nearly every day so don't
miss out these deals are happening every
single day on their fabulous items we're
especially thankful for honey love this
season because there's nothing worse
than suffering caused by uncomfortable
bras or shapewear they have
revolutionized the bra and shapewear
game I'm a big big fan of their
shapewear I have a lot of their control
top items that I got many years ago
they've lasted really well I've watched
them a thousand times I've taken them on
like every trip I've ever been on and I
just love honey love I found them
through a Facebook ad like a million
years ago so you know that feeling when
you get home from a long day and you
immediately want to take off your bra
well with honey love you'll never
experience that again their best-selling
crossover bra is so comfortable it's
sure to be your new go-to this bra gives
you all the support of traditional bras
without using any underwires and if
you're tired of bras causing that
bulging in the back their bras are
designed with back smoothing fabric to
prevent that bulge when it comes to
shapewear their superow short is the
go-to targeted compression technology
distinguishes between areas that you
want support and areas that you need
less impression in so give the gift of
comfort this holiday season whether
you're attending a wedding hosting a
friends giving family dinner or just
seeking everyday boosts of confidence
Honey Love is the perfect plus one treat
yourself to the best bras and shapew we
on the market and save up to 20% off
sitewide at Honey love.com toast this
month only after you purchase they'll
ask you where you heard about them
please support the toast tell them we
sent you it's time to ditch the
underwire for good thanks to Honey Love
that's honey
lv.com toast honey love.com
save up to 20% off
sitewide thank you la you're welcome our
first story some podcasting
news Amy robach and TJ Holmes the GMA 3
lovers have launched a new podcast
together on the oneyear anniversary of
their Scandal they are talking about
their year of Hell post Scandal oh wow
the oued gma3 co-host look back on their
relationship coming to light in November
2022 in the first episode of their Amy
and TJ podcast Amy teared up while
telling listeners that she wanted to die
as they navigated the Fallout she said
there were days when I wanted to die
that was something I never experienced
before in my life I just didn't want to
get up I didn't want to see what new
headlines was going to be out there
elsewhere in the episode she got
emotional as she elaborated on the dark
time TJ experienced after their romance
went public which led her to doing a
wellness check on her partner in a
terrifying moment she will never forget
she said her Panic began when she was
receiving texts from him in the past
tense as well as messages from ABC
producers trying to get in touch with
him she was so hysterical she was afraid
he had done something that she went over
to his house and got into his room with
the door man's help she said you were
just spay out on your bed I ran to you
and I said TJ and you didn't move it was
most awful thing having to touch your
body and see if you were warm I was so
afraid you were just incoherent he
explained how he ended up in the state
he was in that day was essentially me
getting off work and pounding vodka I
didn't stop for several hours and took
who knows how many weed edibles the duo
who have proved they're still going
strong with a joint half marathon and a
recent red carpet debut went on to
assure listeners that they are happier
than ever and in love no seriously going
through like a public cancellation like
will make you suicidal like and you
really have to experience it to
understand like how [__] traumatizing
it is and I actually believe these two
like this sounds hard they went through
it bad especially they have a unique
situation which I I kind of understand
is like the level of Fallout that they
received wasn't congruous with the level
of Fame they were I had never heard of
these two people most people had it
let's be real nobody's watching the
third hour of GMA but the level of
attention they got was that of Matt low
you know their counterpart yeah and so
when your level of Fame and success is
so much lower than the level of
attention you get for something negative
it could be really really jarring yeah
cuz it's also your first experience with
that level of Fame and it's a negative
at least when you're like always getting
positive attention and then something
negative comes you know how to handle
the mass amounts of attention no but it
counteracts you know you get a lot of
the good you get the bad no but it's
also just that amount of people knowing
you for the first time and have it be
something bad that's how you're getting
used to the spotlight but then it's also
so important to remember like yes
something bad they were Unfaithful which
is terrible nobody died no and when it
happened like I feel like we were pretty
measured about that I think they should
have kept their jobs I think people
might have watched the third hour of GMA
I don't know why they had to be fired
for this right I do I assume like
legally there's some sort of like
morality clause in their contracts and
this violates that thus giving GMA a
reason to fire them I just don't know
why GMA would want want to a morality
Clause is subjective and it can be used
to fire someone when they are looking
for a reason to fire them but they also
don't they don't have to fire someone
because they did some something immoral
in fact they rarely do yeah I don't know
why I agree I think this was good for
the irrelevant hour of GMA 3 who even
knew that that existed and like these
two people they had both said that they
were separated it's not like they you
know just hooked up like they were in a
relationship and they're still going
strong so to have a third hour of GMA
with a couple love birds it's giving Ma
and Joe yes no it's giving Intrigue it's
giving interesting finally and now
they're trying to do it on Kelly and
Mark and live right right Kelly and Mark
and live yeah they wanted to bring the
romance into that morning programming
and they already have a romance here
yeah I don't know how successful their
podcast is going to be but I do respect
the hustle I respect capitalizing on the
moment and being open and honest about
what going through something like that
is like yeah I also wonder what their
podcast will be about going forward like
obviously this is the episode maybe they
can even do this for a while just like
talking about what their year I'm going
to go to their podcast in the store and
like see the description and the
category like are they going to do news
are they news people right because they
were like anchors yeah so they've got
the bug and who is producing said
podcast is ihart radio radio which makes
sense because they were just on the
iHeart Radio red carpet being super
handsy and cute and bringing Buzz to an
iHeart Radio event so it's in society
and culture Amy and TJ is hosted by
renowned TV news anchors blah blah blah
host and executive producers Amy and TJ
are formidable broadcasting team with
Decades of experience delivering
headline news and captivating viewers
Nationwide now the duo will get behind
the mic to explore meaningful
conversations about current events pop
culture and everything in between
nothing is off limits okay so it's going
to be like takes and the two of them
it's going to be like about anything
possible it doesn't sound like they're
pigeon holding themselves into a
particular Niche no and it's not going
to be necessarily news it's it's not in
the news category and it's not going to
be guests really either so it's going to
be the two of them talking about the
world which is what we do and can be
done well if you have something
interesting to say in our funny Dynamic
girlies the cream Rises so you know we
shall see stay tuned for the Flop or the
success of the TJ and Amy podcast the TJ
Amy
yeah it's funny how when like you go to
podcasting now she's like wearing a
sweatshirt whereas like when she was um
you know on GMA 3 like always blouse you
know no she's slumming it with us now no
but like now it's true for something
about podcasting like you have to dress
down it's like weird to dress up for a
podcast which is what I'm doing right
now and I feel weird it it's not weird
to dress up for a podcast but you do
your best work podcasting is such a
comfortable medium and if you do it
right you do it with someone you're
totally comfortable with and you you
share share things that maybe you
wouldn't share ordinarily and doing that
in a crew neck uggs and a and leggings
it just you will perform better it's
math I can't explain it that's not my
exact feeling on the matter CU you could
be comfortable I'm super comfortable in
my sea super it's different it's
different it's about the look I can't
and she's not even wearing the big
headphones she'll get there maybe it's
also cuz you're typically on a couch you
want sit on in a dress on a couch but
but all the late night shows have
couches yeah and they look uncomfortable
when they sit there they do actually
they're like the girls sitting at the
edge of the couch with their legs they
don't look comfortable yeah but the
whole thing is uncomfortable so it's
good to stay uncomfortable yeah but
podcasting like we're going to pull it
out of you so you might as well be
comfortable might as well bearings maybe
it's also the length of podcasting it's
very long you can't sit like that at the
edge of a couch for over an hour an hour
no but you're doing a three minute hit
on Jimmy Fallon you can you know sit
upright for three minutes if you must
100% And it's the headphones they just
require everything to they change things
dress differently it changes things it
changes things so that's what's new for
Amy and TJ and GMA missed out sorry you
did I agree flop Central for GMA 3 the
thing is like we told you at the time we
all told you nobody was calling for
their heads no one was calling for these
two to be removed from air air like
nobody really cared we were just like if
they had this is Juicy the Scandal was
really I mean aside from them having an
affair but like things got negative when
they got fired if they had kept their
jobs and cruised
through no and if we were able to then
like tune in to the maybe they take a
week off and then they come back and
everybody would tune in and be like oh
is it awkward are they going to say
anything it creates Intrigue it's like
PR 101 this was so dumb it's weird it's
almost like they wanted them out for
other reasons and this was the perfect
excuse but like what other reasons no I
don't know they're good hosts they seem
like lovely people who you know
occasionally are separated and fall in
love with their coworker mhm happens it
happens I fell in love with my coworker
I was about to say I'm falling in love
with you turo I told you today's episode
is gonna be so
cute are you ready for our next story
super super cute book news SCB wait scbn
super super super SSS C great BN Memoir
dropping today celebrity Memoir who one
of tur's favorite people who is dropping
his Memoirs today
his who Memoirs of a
Keenan is that the name no I wish oh I'm
just waiting for a celebrity to name
their book that his book is called when
I was your age and it drops today he
talks about name yeah he talks about how
it was terrifying to get personal in his
Memoir but he knew he should lay it all
out
there um at book club yesterday we did
talk a lot about how Matthew Perry's
book was amazing the title was horrible
what's it called friends lovers and the
big terrible thing oh that's that's not
memorable and he talked in the book how
he almost called the book unaccompanied
minor because there's like this fluid
story about the first time he got sent
to go visit his dad who abandoned him
and it was like this traumatizing thing
he realized he had this fear of
Abandonment and like that would have
been a better title yeah or because he
never grew up for he never grew out of
that or Memoirs of a
Matthew no it doesn't hit the same it
like Memoirs of a Keenan was good it's
literally the same because it's the same
syllables okay if I wrote another book
how would I make it Memoirs of a tury or
something
right it's better when it starts with a
g Memoirs of a
gweni love
love anyway Memoirs of aen also called
when I was your age life lessons funny
stories and questionable parenting
advice from a professional clown that's
funny that's a title that's that's funny
it should have been called advice from a
professional
clown I do love like a a title and then
a subtitle this one is very long and it
only needed to be that it also could
have been Confessions of a professional
clown yeah I love that
love I think that Keenan's a great
person to write a book because he really
has lived of course he is like so famous
now I mean just as my Uber driver
but but he had like a real real career
as a child star that makes for a great
Memoir yeah and he's continued to work
he seems to have a very good head of his
shoulder so like I want his advice yeah
I would take his advice he's a
hardworking person he's a successful
person he's a parent F person he's got
something to say I would Venture and
he's funny exactly so like the writing
is probably good and funny funny yeah
and he also writes for a living right
this is the perfect candidate for a
memoir I'm going to add it I'm literally
going to take on my good reads and add
it otherwise I will completely forget
same but when you tell me how many pages
it is just before I I'm at a time of
year where I really can't commit to
anything more than like 350 Pages oh but
I do feel like this is going to be like
the perfect sort of book for this time
of year
240 oh I'm my way literally reading it
today hold on I'm adding it to my good
reads as well and also feel free to spam
the comments with like good short books
I'm going to do like a couple Freedom MC
fatens Things That Go quickly
gsbs gsbs okay yeah Freedom MC faten
always let me see if I've read anything
recently that I would recommend to you
Keenan why is it coming up k n a n you
have to keep writing it's not in the
good reads algorithm t h o m p s o n
yeah and it only has two ratings that's
why want to read but he looks so cute on
the cover he's kind of like a peom
Beyond oh that'll be
good yeah so that's very exciting book
news of the day that is exciting while
we're in our celebrity Memoirs era and I
did say I want to read more non-fiction
and that falls into this category and I
feel like it's going to be one of those
books after you read it where you just
like end up loving the person you know
for sure well this was what he said he
did in an interview with people like
talking about writing a memoir and he
said it's terrifying to open yourself up
like that because I guess I've not had
to do that you know what I mean I've
always been so performance heavy I
haven't had to do a whole lot of stuff
of let me explain where Keenan is now
kind of stuff every interview is usually
about the project or stuff like that
it's rarely about me personally this is
the first time that I'm kind of offering
all of that to people it's scary but
it's cool he also you know explains if
you're going to write a memoir you might
as well just lay it all out there which
is exactly how I feel like if you're
taking the time to write your Memoirs I
want the truth
no yeah and no matter how like
horrifying or embarrassing it is like
that Matthew Perry's had so much stuff
I'm like I can't believe he shared that
like how many times he [__] the bed
because of his addiction I felt that way
about Josh peek's book too like very
honest about his addiction to the point
where I was like damn I don't even know
if I would have shared that yeah but I
feel like if you can't be honest in
general in your book then then it's not
the time to write run or it's not the
story to tell so true so I mean you
could obviously keep a few things
personal but like the overarching story
like you got him
yeah I mean what's the point otherwise
agre write a fiction book yeah if you
don't want to go there like Snookie
remember when Snookie wrote a fiction
book no about a little girl who goes to
the Jersey Shore love it obsessed
remember when Kylie and Kendall wrote
one about those two like mystical
fairies yeah it's giving Sisterhood of
the Traveling bands I literally thought
the same thing so that's your book news
next story a little more related book
news for me Britney Spears is a strange
dad Jamie has had his leg amputated
after a terrible infection Britney's a
strange father Jamie had his leg
amputated last month a source in the pop
star's Hometown hometown of Kentwood
Louisiana told page six quote he had a
knee replacement and got a terrible
infection from it we hear j e underwent
multiple unsuccessful surgeries prior to
the amputation which was a last
resort you know our God is not a
merciful god he vengeful and listen you
rep put
yourself like I'm not going to sit here
saying feel better like yeah a bad
person yeah not not the best especially
after having read the book um right and
we this news came out after we recorded
the redhead so I'm not sure you know
what would have changed right an
anecdote you know there was talk at one
point about Theo possibly amputating his
leg cuz the cancer uh had gotten into
his bones but they didn't think he would
be a good candidate actually I do have a
Theo update
yesterday was Theo's second radiation
appointment and we've been just like
waiting to know if radiation is helping
at all there's no guarantee and after
yesterday's scans and and second round
of radiation we did find out that in
since week one this is four a four-week
program as of yesterday he had only had
one week under his belt the tumor had
not shrunk but it hadn't grown and I
have to believe at the rate that things
escalated so quickly in the last couple
of weeks that it was going to continue
to grow the fact that it didn't grow I
think is a good sign
yeah the fact that it didn't grow kind
of means that it shrunk cuz the growth
the growth that would have been was
shrunken yeah I I want to assume that
like next week the pre-existing
tumor might shrink I'm really hoping
yeah so he did another round yesterday
he has another round of acupuncture this
week and then we'll see I think next
week we'll be like really telling but I
keep saying that you know no it's good
it's
good yeah it's because it's not bad it's
true it's true like it could have spread
yeah you didn't get bad news and
therefore no news is good news yes
that's true that is thank you my life
motto it's true yeah but it's when
you're actually the one experiencing it
it's like [__] off with your motto you
know no no no
sure but it's helpful mottos can be I
mean when you the word motto I don't
like but having just like
truths yes to cling to like in the heat
in the height of Theo's like drama
you're just going to continue to do the
next right thing and you know what that
brought me peace I feel like I'm always
trying to tell you about this song from
Frozen 2o called do the next right thing
you've got to listen to it no I just
like when you say it to me like that's
so heartbreaking Anna doesn't know where
to go where to turn what's she going
through she's kind of like lost in a
cave um Elsa like left because you know
Elsa's like does superior things with
her El's also like selfish oh yeah she's
kind of a wench and she just like never
trusts that Anna can handle anything but
Anna's still going to try and do it so
Elsa you might as well have brought her
with you instead you left your little
sister in a cave Olaf has melted Anna
has no one and what can she do the next
right thing the next right thing just
one foot in front of the other yeah
literally until she gets out of the cave
right and she can like build Olaf back
up right so is Olaf not in the film no
he is he is he was in it and then he
melts and like then it's like wears the
spirit of Olaf and then with Anna's
Elsa's powers like she can bring him
back right but like how long is he miss
how long is he missing like an hour just
no no no in the chunk of the movie where
things you know where there's a dip at
the 75% of every movie like three qus of
the way through like things get bad is
at her lowest Ola Gan at the end happy
ending got it so spoiler alert are you
ready for our next story is it our
fourth story our fourth story that's
brought to you by stamps.com did you
forget to add stamps.com to your holiday
wish list this year Well we all make
mistakes stamps.com has been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money during the holiday rush for 25
years with easy access to USPS and UPS
services and premium rates for all your
postage needs the holidays are hard
enough make things easier than ever with
stamps.com it's your own post personal
post office wherever you are all you
need is a computer and a printer they'll
even send you a free scale so you'll
have everything you need to get started
taking care of orders on the go is even
easier with the stamps.com mobile app if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart if you're running low
ordering shipping and mailing supplies
labels and even printers from the supply
store is super easier and most
importantly you're getting huge carrier
discounts up to 84% off USPS and UPS
rates to help your bottom line they'll
automatically tell you on stamps.com
what the cheapest and fastest shipping
options available are for 25 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over million businesses get access to
the USPS and UPS services that you need
right from your computer at any time day
or night no lines no traffic no waiting
sounds like heaven whether you run a
business you ship out a lot having a
stamps.com account Will Change Your Life
Trust and Believe give your business the
gift of stamps.com so your mailing and
shipping is covered this holiday season
sign up with promo code toast for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale with no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and code toast thank you Claudia I have
something to say please hit us today's
episode is also brought to you by
Dreamland baby I've told you guys about
the Dreamland baby weighted sleep sack
and I'm telling you again because
they're having an amazing BOGO deal
right now so I use the weighted sleep
sack it is exactly what it sounds like a
sleep sack for babies that has a little
bit of weighted in it you might be
familiar with this technology from a
weighted blanket for adults that calms
you reduces anxiety this weighted sleep
sack does that for baby it is is so
amazing it can be slept in three
different ways for the baby arms in one
arm out both arms out that way it can be
used for children different stages of
age you know if they still have the
startle reflex if they don't they can
sleep arms out whatever really works for
your baby every baby's different baby
sleep is more personal than comedy more
personal than food we love our Dreamland
weighted sleep sacks it also Zips from
top to bottom and bottom to top for easy
diaper changes throughout the night and
right now with their buy 1 get one sale
you can get two for the price of one so
if you want to be generous and gifted
that's very sweet of you personally I
need at least two of these sleep sacks
because when one of course when one's in
the laundry like I don't want to be so
duh Dreamland is having their biggest
sale of the year go to Dreamland babco
tocom and use code the toast BOGO 23 at
checkout for the buy 1 get one free
weighted products deal this is a great
way to stock up on Dreamland baby
products or to give as a holiday gift if
you are a magnanimous king or queen
which is your prerogative but I would
keep the two for myself just saying so
check it out check out the sale all
right fourth story let me guess what's
going I feel like not A lot's going on
in the world like I couldn't think of
what stories we would be talking about
today all of the stories like it was
actually a good day for stories in the
sense that some days there's absolutely
nothing some days there's like one or
two biggies and then the three I can't
find anything these were five that came
together I couldn't even figure out a
way to order them because they're all of
equal to little importance understood
including the fact that Kim Kardashian
is going to be playing a Laura waser
inspired lawyer in a new drama series
and Chris is executive
producing so Kim is adding even more to
her acting resume now she will play LA's
most successful divorce lawyer and the
owner of an all female law firm in a
legal drama per deadline the show is
being written by brothers and sisters
Creator and playwright John Robin Bates
exec goow back to brothers and sisters
like always being on after Desperate
House when we were like 11 did anybody
ever watch being like our pity view
because we couldn't turn off the
television so true executive produced by
Ryan Murphy streamed on Hulu and also
produced by Chris Jenner the role is
reportedly based on Fame divorce lawyer
Laura waser who is represented numerous
a-listers including Ryan Reynolds
Angelina jool Lee Britney Spears and
Kevin cner reminds me of that character
that Laura Duran played in where was she
like a very funny famous divorce lawyer
it might have been marriage story yes I
didn't see that she was great in that um
and so funny I actually read an article
yesterday where Ted sarandos the CEO of
Netflix was saying that expect to see a
lot of lawyer TV shows in the next year
on different platforms because of the
success suits is having on Netflix and
this just sounds like that yeah it does
that makes sense yeah um I am still like
Beyond confused with Kim's recent
obsession with becoming like a famous
actor director Hollywood you know artist
it literally makes no sense to me she
did a very good job in the Ryan Murphy
thing and I understood the Ryan Murphy
first thing as like doing it once
proving to everyone that you could do it
having it on your resume Ryan Murphy's
iconic like I totally got it and the
character she played was so Kim like it
was this Hollywood PR girl but making a
career of it like I I don't understand
everything Kim has done like I do
understand like I understand wanting to
be a lawyer I understand wanting to be
like a the biggest fashion house like I
understand everything she's done thus
far I don't understand this no me
neither unless it feels like a step back
it does feel like a step back and like
something that she surpassed a long time
ago like when there was a time to be an
actress would have been you know years
ago but now she's accomplished so much
more than acting unless they say like
maybe she has an acting bug maybe this
is a passion maybe she's at the point in
her life where like she's done so much
for her business and her and her family
and her wallet and now she wants to
pursue her passions Maybe that I would
understand that I would understand
especially because she said on a recent
episode of Kardashians that she actually
lost money doing the American Horror
Story thing because she rented this like
billion dollar apartment in New York for
the time that she had to be there so she
ended up losing money and so I would
hope this is a passion yeah you lose
money on your passions and that's okay
that's why you do the things that you're
not passionate about right in order to
fund your passions and I feel like maybe
at her age she's like I want to be
creative and artistic and she's just in
this era of creativity art that I would
actually understand yeah actually I
would as well but I think everything Kim
does is so
strategic maybe she's tired of being
strategic and she just wants to be a
part of the theater maybe do you ever
feel that way
no however I could also see this
strategically being like her way of
maybe following in like the Reese mold
where you know you get involved then you
create a production company and then you
have a billion dollar business you know
but she had has a billion dollar
business but I think what we learned
from the most recent season of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians is that it's
never
enough I I that's Courtney was saying
yes it does seem to be the
obvious answer like she wants to do more
she wants to conquer every single field
just to say that she can't prove the
haters wrong which is what she's like
always saying but this is just like too
far so I feel like it can't be that
because that doesn't make sense for this
no I agree I would love for someone to
just tell me like what's going on cuz I
am confused she has a passion for
acting
okay I'm confused too yeah it's just not
adding up the show sounds good I mean it
kind of sounds like Drop Dead Diva
but I'm so glad so glad you brought up
Drop Dead Diva and Kim was I'm Drop Dead
Diva so maybe that's where she got the
bug Kim was on drop dead deer so I think
that's where she wanted wanted to pursue
this and I think she's been waiting all
these years cuz she was just an extra I
think she saw what they were doing on
that set and said one day I'm going to
make my so self so big so powerful so
successful that they can't ignore me you
guys if you have never watched Drop Dead
Diva it is the best it was on Netflix
when I watched it I don't know where it
is now hopefully it's still on Netflix
and I don't know how many seasons there
were but let me tell you it was the best
show I'd ever watched in my life like
for real I didn't love it I know we've
had this conversation yeah I just need
to just say that but now but I love how
much you love it and it didn't like
offend me or anything nobody loved it
more than Ben Sofer he was obsessed it's
a good show like it's not offensive it's
super cute and you learn like legal
jargon along the way and it's just like
well done also Zach has been watching
Suits so I kind of like weigh in and out
like when I'm getting a snack in the
kitchen and one of the episodes like
there was a McKenzie file yes there was
I noted that as well I was like
jckie because we didn't like pull the
McKenzie file out of thin air it was so
classic it was classic stuff but it's
not like we we ever watch suits like
Jackie it's on it's on the west sng like
it's on everything grab the Mackenzie
file and head into my office yeah it's
always the Mackenzie file it is the
Mackenzie file what did McKenzie do it's
a good question I think I know I think I
know
too Kim
WD what are you
doing yeah are you ready for our fifth
and final
Story the final
story yes I'm ready People magazine is
making a list checking it twice People
magazine is pretending they interviewed
Taylor Swift let's call it what it is
they have a new uh list and Topping the
most intriguing people of the year for
2023 is tailored Swift for them they
have a gorgeous cover and speaking to
people in her life about why she's the
most intriguing person of the year I
don't know if this is a new category
that they've launched people it's like a
new list people's most intriguing I feel
like everybody has their thing like they
have times most
influential well that's what I wanted to
talk about because there's a lot of
speculation now um times person of the
year is coming out soon and you know who
people think it's going to be of course
a lot of people think it's going to be
Taylor but they do
um they go like Rogue you know they'll
do like Putin or you know yeah yeah I
think last year it
was I I didn't it was my episode with
dumois oh I think it was um
zalinski right so they don't always go
for like the obvious like American
Choice yeah well let me I love looking
at it really has to be Taylor right but
wait here are the nine finalists oh oh
maybe that's why people were talking
about it okay no and also like it's
almost time okay finalist for the Times
person of the year Hollywood
Strikers
okay um the president of China president
shei what's his name it's XI but I think
it's pronounced she shei yeah XI
jingping also not pronounced correctly
okay Taylor Swift is a finalist see
that's like why the the the crop of
people is so weird yeah
um Sam mman is a finalist he should not
win no no I'm sorry we we we just found
out his name like collectively as a you
know as a generation last week yes um he
had like one one Buzzy week but I guess
he also like invented chat GP and it was
kind of the Year honestly AI should be
the person of the year no literally like
a robot yeah that would be very poetic
next nomination Trump
prosecutors okay like is that a group of
people uh yeah oh I guess like the SAG
people are also a group so it could be
like a a crew I think at one point it
was like you know the nurses of Co right
right right they do groups sometimes
that's true they do groups which I like
a person I like a person too it's the
person of the year next
Barbie Margo Robbie no Barbie like tra
TM if Barbie is our person of the year
we've lost we have trouble yeah like
yeah take a look at the year and bar
maybe that would be a signal to the
ridiculous state of the World perhaps
next option Vladimir Putin yeah like
that's so classic time I feel like there
are a bunch of people who who are kind
of finalists every year always in the
running like elon's not on the list but
he should be yeah uh next finalist King
Charles Cavalier Spaniel II yeah he's he
didn't really make much of an impact but
heated this year after I see why he
would be qualified time of waiting I you
know what it's not it wasn't his year at
all but like technically it was no if
there ever was a year it would be this
year and the fact that it's not is just
so sad for him and then the last one is
Jerome Powell who is the chairman of the
Federal Reserve I just feel like things
aren't really going well over there so
maybe not his year also by the way but
when time names a person of the year it
doesn't always mean good no no but it's
like that's like Osama Bin Laden was the
person of the year when everybody hated
him now we love him but yeah I think at
one point Hitler was the person of the
year right so it doesn't always mean
it's not always a positive Accolade like
if Kaylor Swift got it of course it
would be but then it's just weird that
there's an award that Taylor swiftz has
gotten and so is Hitler you know yeah
let's go to the last few years even
though we do this every year I'm sure
you guys can't remember
either hold
on I promise that you'll never find
another like
me
do you need help okay sorry I'm
struggling you want me to start looking
up to yeah I'm just like it's not as
okay oh it started in 1927 with Charles
Lindberg let me just confirm that at one
point oh 1936 Wallace Simpson I feel
that oh yeah but see that's not
necessarily positive no no but she led
to the advocate like she was it was her
year right uh 1938 was Hitler 1939 was
Stalin but see in 38 and 39 do you think
they were naming them in a positive way
cuz we didn't know what was to come you
know no uh it wasn't in like a super
positive way but in the sense that he
was you know influential and it was his
big year but right he'd been prattling
on about his genocidal Tendencies for
years at that point it wasn't really a
secret um and by then you know onuses
had happened like Germany and Austria
unification 1939 was Stalin 1940 was
Winston Churchill okay can you just do
the highlights though like you don't
have to go through everything for sure
to me these are highlights yeah no no
you're doing a good job I just want to
make sure you weren't going to go like
you no I wasn't but like these are
wartime and it's you know at least they
had their priorities in order it wasn't
Barbie in 1941 it was Franklin delanor
Roosevelt 1942 Stalin got it again damn
1943 George damn double homicide 1943
George C Marshall who was a okay you
could have skipped okay 1944 Eisenhower
194 SK 1945 Truman okay now we'll keep
going because there was a lot
of heads of state 1952 Elizabeth II when
she was seeding the throne will'll keep
going all the way down let's go to
recent history last year was oh I'm
sorry it wasn't
zilinski it was the spirit of
Ukraine okay okay so it's not even a
person it's a
spirit I just feel like that's a
loophole like just why don't you do the
people of Ukraine like the spirit the
spirit it says it right here oh oh I'm
sorry it was it was zalinsky there were
two winners it was zilinsky and the
spirit of Ukraine okay at least there
was an actual person it's a person of
the year yeah okay before that so this
year it should be the spirit of the
Israelis it should by Logic by 2021 it
was Elon Musk okay in 2020 it was Joe
Biden and Camala Harris was that the
year they won uh
yes okay but they hadn't been in yet
right right right that's that's so
confusing by the way 2019 Greta
tunberg G I've had enough of her that
doesn't age well no neither did she
oh 2018 it was the Guardians who are
journalists who faced persecution arrest
or murder for their reporting okay so
was four oh no yeah four different
reporters okay 2017 was the silence
Breakers the people who spoke out
against sexual abuse and harassment
including the figureheads of the
American me too movement of the disgrace
to me to movement and also Taylor Swift
was a part of that one yes and Ashley
Jud Susan Fowler and heads of the me to
movement so that doesn't really age well
either no 2016 was Donald Trump the year
he was elected 2015 Angela Merkel
chancellor of Germany oh she's so
classic that lady classic I don't even
think she is a leader anymore but she's
just like always I don't know anything
about her but there's something about
her name Merkel like that's my girl it's
like Markle Sparkle
off is the Merkel
Sparkle
yes
yes yes in 2014 it was the Ebola
Fighters oh what did we know then I'm
surprised like fouchy never got it oh
yeah and what about our girl Deborah
Burks no she was um a flash in the pan
yeah yeah she didn't have what it took
honestly she got fired and honestly I
think it had to do with her being on the
toast like no but like she was just like
not about it she like this she was more
about the scarves she was about the
scarves and she was about the work and
then I think she saw where things were
going she's like I'm happy to be fired
by you clowns yeah meanwhile fouchi took
it all the way yeah and he didn't even
at Time person of the year No but he got
like everything else yeah yeah yeah I'm
not I'm not worried about him in his
accolades um and then do you want to
hear 2013 Pope Francis no so it does
sound like they don't often do like a
celebrity pop culture moment however
this year has been unprecedented for
Taylor Swift so I actually do think she
could win I do think she could win too
so who is your prediction based on read
them again right now knowing what we
know the Hollywood Strikers no they have
a chance based on the fact that that the
last few year like it hasn't been a
group of people in a few years they do
have a chance but I don't think it's
going to be them I don't think their
impact was greater than Taylor Swift
president
shei I don't know there's a lot going on
with China and granted I don't
understand all of it albeit most of it
but I do know that he's powerful so I'll
yes maybe I think he will win I don't
think it's his year it's giving 49
oh okay you know like a Super Bowl team
for sure not his year okay Taylor has
more in him yeah he's got more to give
yeah I it's someone else's time and it
could be Taylor Swift but that would be
crazy actually if she got it just based
on like it's typically heads of state or
yeah but seriously like every head of
people every head of state of countries
that Taylor visited like bowed down to
Taylor like she's on that level yeah no
no no I agree Sam Alman no no Trump
prosecutors no even though they do like
a group yeah but I'm gonna think no
Barbie please no for the sake of
humanity okay but like it's impact what
like no I'm not saying they deserve it
I'm saying like I could see them giving
it to Barbie for
real it was Barbie Mania you have to
think about the year okay and but it was
also like manufactured Barbie Mania no
and they love to do something different
like you know it's not a person it's a
group it's it's a spirit it's a b it's a
doll like I could see it I I agree that
they would like to give it to Barbie but
I just don't think that they can do that
and still be considered like serious
right now true Vladimir Putin again I
don't think it's his time I I don't feel
like he did a lot this year I'm sure he
did but like in the grand scheme of a
global I don't I hearing his name a lot
I don't know but then if you think back
to the 193s it was like Hitler Stalin
Roosevelt you know last year was Ukraine
this year might be him it kind of of
there's a pattern yeah next King Charles
III no no and Jerome Powell no so it's
really between Taylor Swift Putin and
the Hollywood
sters I'm gonna say Taylor Swift and I
also think giving it to Barbie would
kind of be in a front to the Hollywood
Strikers is all I'm saying so true so
true so I think those two cancel each
other out Taylor Swift yeah I feel
confident actually in saying that it
will be Taylor Swift oh I hope we don't
have to wait too long to find out but
that's just the weird thing about Time
person of the year like it goes to
people like Taylor Swift and Stalin you
know yeah but we looking at the list
that we just read it really doesn't go
to people like Taylor Swift like Taylor
Swift right like have the Beatles ever
gotten it I'm sure that they have I need
to go back to that page I was on that
was hard to find um cuz I feel like the
only real comparable music group or
musician in history to what we're
experiencing with Taylor Swift now is
the Beatles with Beetle Mania and I'm
sure that they have gotten Time person
of the
year what year would that have been like
the the 60s
60s Apollo 8 astronauts that's a good
one I'm not seeing the Beatles yet damn
damn American women that's nice that's a
Miss yeah that is Miss really there's
not I can't see one comp to Taylor Swift
not one well her winning would be like
another historic thing she sets the
precedent for no based on this it would
be historic if she won there's not I
mean I'm closest person to that I can
see in my brief scroll is like Mark
Zuckerberg B and that's not even a comp
no it's not a comp who was the one that
we said in the beginning hold on it felt
like he Wallace Simpson right that's but
that's still like a head of state Vibe
no no no I know it would
be really a major if she won actually
okay well now now I'm actually looking
forward to seeing who they choose yeah
but if she doesn't win she can take
Solis and knowing that she was people's
most intriguing person of the year right
so there's always that cushion the blow
cushioning the below well as predicted
that was an incredibly cute show
Beyond and Jackie and her sew are
offs are are done with the stories me
and my incredibly oversized cardigan cuz
I'm so small and fil are feeling good
about today's episode and hope everybody
enjoyed so thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
[__] subscribe and give this video a
[__] thumbs up we're also
available as a goddamn
podcast anywhere podcasts are available
so that means Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I Radio cast boox all the
places whever you listen to podcast by n
to if I serve you but a beautiful
stunning and kidly talented we are hope
you guys have an amazing day and we'll
see you tomorrow for hump day love you
bye